it was civilians that were injured from
Russia invading they don't believe that
it was their army they think that it's
lies Ukraine is defending himself it's
defending its sovereignty from an
invading force that wants to ethnically
cleanse who they are current invasion of
Ukraine is the first conflict that I've
covered we create empathy with our
audiences and make them want to care
about the situations that we care about
and cover I wouldn't feel proud of
taking a picture of like an injured
person it's final Act of Ukraine's
Revolution and separation from the USSR
and the Soviet Union and Russia
I'm uh Wolfgang Chuan I'm a photographer
I've been in Ukraine for about a year
now and mostly working for on a dolu
Agency for the wire service well I have
been making photos for maybe four years
or so I've been working in news for
about two years current invasion of
Ukraine is the first conflict that I've
covered I don't think that I had a
desire to be a war photographer I had a
desire to want to come here and learn
more about Ukraine and learn more about
the history of what had been happening
in Dome boss in the sort of
the culture in the East and the rest of
Ukraine and why this has happened and
unfolded the way it has I think that I
just sort of fell into covering a
conflict while wanting to learn more
about why this has happened
[Music]
attention when I first came here was to
work in a longer more environmental
story but in the Dom boss region on the
coal mines out there and the neglect of
those because of the
the war that had started in 2014
and ended up finding more steady work
working for the wire shooting daily life
of soldiers in the trenches on the
Ukrainian side for most of the time that
I've worked here I've worked for anadolu
agency which is a wire service they will
it'll be just like pure fact pure photos
what's happening more Daily News and
then those photos can be used by any
publication or newspaper or magazine in
the world website whatever have you
um so it's our job to as a wire
photographer to go find stories and
anticipate what will be useful to the
larger media Market in the coming days
or weeks or if it's that day if it's
breaking news for instance I was here in
Kiev on the 10th of this month and or
the 10th of October sorry um and that
day Rockets Were Striking
all right
[Music]
that day it's my job to try to get to
the scene as quickly as possible make
photos of that and get them out as fast
as possible so that somewhere like CNN
or MSNBC or whatever publication out
there can use those photos and their
stories as quickly as possible this last
trip we're heading into winter in
Ukraine and a lot of people in the east
in these liberated territories are
dealing with lack of electricity they're
dealing with lack of heat through blown
up gas lines and whatnot it was a little
bit of my objective on this trip to
cover those issues of people dealing
with those circumstances because there
will be a lot more stories going forward
into the winter on those problems
[Music]
hitting the War I think that it looked
like from the outside that this would
happen coming here in January and
speaking to ukrainians I the
overwhelming sense that I got from
almost everyone here was that of course
that won't happen Russia won't invade
and for basically up until like two days
before the war
everyone that I talked to did not think
that this would happen and from speaking
a little bit at depth with folks I I
came to the conclusion I think that it
was a little bit of the boy that cried
wolf with a lot of people here and a
fatigue of Russia doing this for so many
years there's been a very similar
buildups the last few years before this
one and I think people just got tired of
worrying is a little bit of like how I
interpreted the conversations that I've
had as far as me being more prepared to
cover the conflict having been here for
a couple months of course if I was here
for years beforehand and had lived in
Ukraine before this and had worked here
a lot more studied here I think I would
be better equipped to tell the story but
I think having come for a few months
beforehand made me able to navigate the
situation at least like have a footing
here have friends have
a little bit more of an understanding
and ease of getting around and being
able to
do my job more effectively to tell the
story of what is happening
[Music]
on the 24th on the first day of the war
I had been
staying in Bach moot for almost two
months I rented a flat out there and I
was working kind of just like all up and
down the front line from like stancia
luhansk in the North all the way down to
marry up all over these two months kind
of the week leading up to the war a lot
more rhetoric was getting pushed Putin
made his speech recognizing the the
annex territories or not annexed at that
point just recognizing the separation of
uh luhansk and dunyatz the night of the
23rd there was a lot of weird movements
with like
on the Russian side there was a complete
media blackout there was no internet for
a lot of people so that seemed weird the
Ukrainian side they shut down every
single airport in the country that night
and it looked like it would happen so we
kind of I was working with uh two
friends and colleagues Alex Laurie and
Justin Yao we were staying together we
were debating going south to mariupal to
work on a story there if it did happen
or to head north to harkov which um
harkiev sorry decided to go to harkiev
with the intention of we'll go and cover
what we can there and if everything
seems like it's collapsing and Russia's
rolling over everything then we'll move
towards Kiev which is on the way out
surprised the entire world maybe it has
surprised themselves with this like
Valiant defense of themselves and at
this point like pushing back the Russian
army anyway so on that day we wake up at
three or four in the morning to the news
that this is starting we pack our bags
get in the car and we head for harkiev
on the way there we're reading Twitter
it looks like the entire country is like
paratroopers are falling on borispell
Kiev is under bombardment so quickly we
make the plan that we are going to make
our way to Kiev thinking that that's
where the story is going to be and as
we're on I believe it's still the E40
but heading up from slavansk to harkiev
at one point we see a big plume of smoke
that using Google Maps and sort of
figuring that out it looks like it's an
air base in chagoyev which is a little
bit south of Park of so
we're heading in that direction the
plume just keeps getting bigger as we're
approaching and as we get into chigoyev
we're looking for the turn where we can
get to this to sort of make photos of
this giant smoke cloud we just by chance
pull into a neighborhood there these old
Khrushchev style apartment buildings and
a missile strike or some sort of large
ordinance had landed right in the middle
of these buildings so we see First
Responders coming in ambulances and
stuff and get out of the car to cover
that situation and this is where the
photo of Elena Carrillo happened uh very
quickly after we Departed the car she
was one of the first people that we had
all seen and made some photos of her got
her information and then continued to
cover the scene I think that day I
didn't understand the gravity of making
that photo because we made those photos
I filed we drove across the country on
back roads without much cell reception
and I was under the impression that what
we witnessed wasn't going to be you
unique for the first day of the war and
it took until like the next day and the
day after to sort of realize that those
sort of images weren't captured
really anywhere else at least the first
day of the war like no one else had
images of an air a civilian area that
had been bombed I thought that that
would be widespread or at least widely
covered and you would be seeing photos
of that from all over the country so I
didn't think that it was going to be as
I don't know unique or stand out as it
was but photo of her that I filed was
one of the first photos that was filed
anywhere in the country that day and it
was civilians that were injured from
Russia invading so became the face of
the war it became the
immediately everyone had to know that
civilians will be harmed in this there's
no way around that like from the first
hours of the war civilians are getting
bombed
I think I felt a
um in a way good to have contributed to
telling the story of
what this war will look like and I think
the civilian suffering is a massive
characteristic of
Russia's Invasion here of Ukraine where
there's no differentiating military
targets from civilian Targets this
entire War for them it's just Total War
so to be able to capture that and put
that on display on the first day and not
let people really look away from what
this is going to be at the time I didn't
really know that but it has become a
characteristic of all of this I've felt
like it's kind of just doing my job it's
not like a proud thing it's not like I
don't think I wouldn't feel proud of
taking a picture of like an injured
person and someone on the worst day of
their life but I feel like I effectively
did the work that I came here to do and
did the situation Justice and helped
show that suffering to a greater
audience we spent about an hour there
covering the police and firemen working
in the building pulling out people that
were injured attending to them and then
we decided to head to harkev thinking
that what we had just witnessed is
happening all across the country so we
head to archieve it's much more calm
seems seemingly normal like people are
there's a very tense feeling in the air
with everyone but people are still
waiting at bus stops like but all
checking their phones and like kind of
looking around like seemingly they're
going to work the other two guys that I
was with they had to file
um we used a friend's Wi-Fi there and
then make our way to Kiev and
on the trip to Kiev we got off of the
E40 the main Highway because it was
gridlocked right after harkov just
complete traffic jam and that's like a
six hour drive normally without traffic
so if it's like bumper to bumper the
whole way it would take forever so we
just took back roads which took 10 hours
from harkov to Kiev with almost like no
cell reception the entire time it was a
really surreal experience knowing that
the war has started seeing what we saw
that morning but having a very calm back
roads drive at the end of winter with
like melting snow and it was like a
clear blue sky that day so like sun's
out very beautiful day but knowing that
all of like this chaos and terror is
happening across the country it was a
very very long day so we had gotten up
at three four a.m on the 24th and then
didn't end the day until we got into
Kiev at midnight one in the morning on
the 25th
[Music]
even on the uh October 10th here in Kiev
I was messaged by a few different
outlets around the world and talked to I
believe it was a Dutch newspaper about
Russian claims or influencer claims that
the women that were hit at the Samsung
building or building 101 building 109 I
believe next to the electrical place
near the train station here in Kiev that
they were actors and it's been an issue
this entire war and I think to people in
Ukraine it's nothing new it's like
there's been Russian propaganda bleeding
into this country for years and years
and years now but for for me this is a
new thing to see here and to have images
that I personally made that day in the
course of hours the image that I made of
Elena is plastered onto a newspaper
article from 2018 with a gas leak
explosion it was
from like from my point of view it was
interesting to see how we have the
expression like how the sausage is made
to that quickly watch
the breaking news that I photographed
turned into a lie and to see people
believing it there's it's kind of
fascinating and terrifying
simultaneously to see the the speed at
which Russia is able to churn out this
disinformation and because it's so fast
it turns out to be effective it's
horrifying it's worrying it's terrible
that like someone's paycheck comes from
doing that sort of work I'm assuming
um but it's going to be it's something
that's widespread across the entire
world it's not unique to here maybe this
is the first time that it's so quick in
our social media age during wartime and
used effectively I think it'll be
interesting to see years from now the
kind of the reach of Russian propaganda
I was having this conversation the other
day with a colleague on we're sort of
just speculating and wondering is this
mostly for Russian consumption
domestically
um so that that population stays in
support of the war they don't question
it they think that whatever their army
is doing they're not really targeting
civilians so that they see civilians
that are injured they don't believe that
it was their army they think that it's
lies or is this kind of reaching around
the world I don't know the answers to
that this is just like questions that I
had and it's there's going to be college
courses on this one day and like the age
of disinformation and we have this in
the United States with like the kind of
like post-truth ERA with Trump and
calling everything fake news and not
believing the the mainstream media and
it's a major issue back home as well
um but I think it's to like go into like
the individual and to humanize it
for Elena that morning to go through
through possible very likely the most
traumatizing event of her entire life
and then to be dragged across the
internet on one end from people just
seeing her through my photo is extra
traumatizing to like an infinite degree
to have your face blown up there
propaganda aside to be the face of this
war and to have media from around the
world wanting to get her information and
contact her and do interviews after
you've suffered so much is crazy and I
can't imagine living through that and
then to have this other part of it where
a huge population believes that you're a
liar and you're full of [__] and I'm
sorry for cursing and to like want to
chastise you online and call you names
or threaten you and threaten your family
is something that I didn't think about
before making that image I don't think
that would have changed my mind prior to
making it because there's still more
value to showing what's happening to the
audience that does believe it which I
believe is much larger than the audience
that would deny that was true her
thoughts on it I'm not entirely sure
I've watched a couple of her interviews
I think that she she has
um everything that I've seen where she
has spoken she's kind of like harnessed
this attention on her and just turned it
straight to helping Ukraine and pointing
that at
more like wanting to inform people on
what's Happening Here how they can help
and um which is really remarkable to
have like a human being go through that
and then be so selfless in the attention
that's shown to them and just point it
to helping hurt people I'm actually
meeting her for the first time when I
leave here and go to Poland she's had a
handful of eye surgeries and is still
doing a few more but she's
fine overall
[Music]
we go out and we make photos on what's
Happening and most of the world believes
that that's true and it's our job to
show the truth and depict these
situations truthfully and try and give
as much information as we can and then
parts of that can be cherry-picked and
used for disinformation or used for
propaganda but that to me that doesn't
even come close to outweighing the need
to show what's Happening that's like a a
byproduct of doing a very important job
is that it's going to be taken by some
people and misconstrued and I think it's
going to take many many many years to
solve and fix the issues there with this
information as well as the rest of the
world I mean this is happening in a lot
of countries that are slipping further
away from democracy and like moving into
just more right-wing politics and like
the discrediting of new Services
everywhere we create empathy with our
audiences and make them want to care
about the city situations that we care
about and cover I guess in a way helping
Ukraine win it's like it's not my job or
my intent really to be here to help
Ukraine win it's like it's my job to
inform the the audience back home on
what's Happening and as a journalist it
shouldn't ever be your job to directly
like come in and like I want to win this
war for this side that's biased I want
to accurately depict what's happening
here and it just so happens that this is
a very just War for Ukraine Ukraine is
defending himself it's defending its
sovereignty from an invading force that
wants to
ethnically cleanse who they are whether
through genocide or whether through just
a ratio of their language their culture
by photographing that and informing a
public back home I think that it's
helping to justify why in my country the
United States is sending billions and
billions and billions of dollars here
um and why they need to do that in a
time I care deeply about what's
happening here through everything that
I've seen the people that I've met
um and would like to articulate that
through photos and help show American
taxpayers why it is that their taxes are
coming to a place on the other side of
the world and why that's really
necessary
foreign
[Music]
basically from the beginning in the
United States like everyone that I've
talked to and kind of seeing things it
seems like it's overwhelming support for
continuing to send Aid here at least
send money send weapons
um there's not overwhelming support at
any point to send American soldiers to
go fight here I think that was very off
the table with our withdrawal from
Afghanistan the United States just got
out of 20 years of boots on the ground
conflict and I don't think that the
American people have the appetite to
dive right back into that most Americans
see what's happening here and they want
to continue to help and you have the
stories of marryable you have the
stories of bucha and then
there's a need to keep supplying this
country so they can defend themselves
and then you see things like the hark of
offensive uh this summer where those
weapons and that Aid is directly helping
Ukraine to win we're funding a conflict
against our number one adversary and
the money's being going exactly to that
and no American Soldier has to die so
I'm not I'm a little confused in why the
more pro-war hawkish side of our
government the GOP is suddenly not in
support of this I'm not super up on U.S
politics at home I say a little bit away
from that but we'll see how that
trickles down into the population at the
moment I'm not super sure I've spent
most of this year here covering this I
haven't spent I've been home for a
little bit less than two months in all
of 2022. I went home for like a month
month and a half and then came back here
to work on some other things
um mainly in Dumb boss and then did the
same thing again where I go home and
then come back here so it's like part of
me has my foot in the door in
Philadelphia with the company and life
there and then part of me wants to
continue to help show what is happening
in Ukraine
um to a wider audience and for me it's
like I've fallen in love with the
country and the food here and the people
and would like to to keep spending time
here to learn more about what it is here
that's happening and why through the
history and talking with people
foreign
[Music]
boss where this is happening it's Dome
bosses the people that are affected and
the people in liver affected and the
people in Dome boss are affected by the
people in the west of Ukraine so it's
it's not that's just the region where
the most fighting has happened that's
the region where sort of like the
explosion happened in 2014
um but it's all of Ukraine's story and I
I would like to keep coming and keep
learning about this and as
things unfold and the situation changes
and this hopefully someday this war
comes to an end and to see how
reconstruction happens like does Ukraine
really
find a way to include those people and
accept this diversity or
make everyone in Ukraine speak Ukrainian
in like a forced way or do they kind of
invite those the people from the East to
be to want to be
more Ukrainian speaking more
I don't know I don't know but like to
bring education and bring money back
into that region and find ways to lift
that up so that they're not looking for
the greener grass on the other side
which I believe happened
[Music]
in the east of Ukraine in harkiev in
dombas I have like a very similar
feeling to like East Coast cities in the
United States where back home like we
have this
kind of like culture on the east coast
of like people are in a hurry they're
like seemingly rude just because they
don't want to like waste time but
they're like rude in a way that like
they're just honest and blunt or like
they're just in a rush and they don't
want to talk to you or they're kind of
like suspicious when like they don't
know someone but very quickly once like
you kind of get past that wall after a
few minutes of talking to someone like
they're the most inviting hospitable
folks that you'll ever meet and like it
has been that exact same experience that
I've with most people that I've met in
the dome boss region in harkev and I'm
not being biased to this is just where
I've spent the most time in Ukraine but
there's a very like a feeling of
familiarity there for me in a way after
spending five minutes or an hour with
someone it's like you feel like a
genuine sincere like open heart from
people and like the sense of humor there
is amazing like the just the culture
there I love it but I need to spend more
time in like the entire rest of Ukraine
but I love I love Kiev I love I've spent
a lot of time in hartkev is great
um only a little bit in in the west the
first time that I left I stayed in Libby
for a few days but
um in Harrison I went there on this trip
for the first time
um and everyone there was I think that
was like the most Smiles that I've
encountered in Ukraine and I think in a
lot of parts of this country there's a
very weird thing where
um in the US you're supposed to just
like if you make eye contact with
someone it's like kind of like normal
that you just like smile and it makes it
less weird but here when you like make
eye contact with a stranger and you
smile like that's a very weird thing for
the person that's being smiled at and I
get the reaction that it's just like
this person wants to sell me something
or they're trying to do something to me
and I don't like why they're smiling at
me but in in Harrison it was actually
like the first time that I experienced
folks like where like you like smile and
wave at someone and they do it back and
it's just like wait am I am I in Ukraine
what is this
yeah
[Music]
after the Russian troops had left the
kievo blast and Sumi and churn ahead in
the spring we went out one day towards
uh jatomer on the westbound highway from
Kiev and there's a lot of like blown up
Russian tanks that are still on the side
of the road and at this time there was a
lot of people coming back from the west
and coming back from Poland or whatever
other country
they had sought Refugee status in and be
now that it's safe they started coming
back home to the rest of the oblast and
to Kiev so on the way on the highway
there's these destroyed Russian vehicles
and it kind of became these like pop-up
stands for like almost like tourism and
like almost like a a monument to this
destroyed tank is proof that like the
Ukrainian Army is winning and like we're
beating this and to someone who was
forced to flee their home and their
their family or whatever they are coming
back and like this is like a proud
symbol that like you're you're winning
and like you beat that adversary so
folks would come and like families would
take selfies or like the little kids
would like hang off of the the cannon on
this tank and a mom would take photos of
them and we're at one of these uh trying
to make images of like selfies and stuff
for like 30 minutes and uh a young woman
came up and had her I think it was her
boyfriend take a photo of her like doing
this like sexy pose in front of the tank
it was like a silly moment but it like
speaks on like so many different like
everything that I just talked about with
these being a monument to Ukraine
winning and these people that had been
displaced like seeing the symbol of that
but then also like speaking to like
where we're at in 2022 and like this is
like a new kind of War where like
everything is on social media how do
people like insert themselves into
what's happening in the world and like
show off and all of this and I think it
was just like
the to me it's like my favorite image
that I've made here because to me it
like speaks to a lot of different things
that we're seeing throughout this
foreign
[Music]
I've met like quite a lot of Ukrainian
photographers here and like just like
brilliant ones
um one of uh like my favorite like the
most inviting sweetest guy in the world
uh on a totally stepanov is uh mainly
conflict photographer who's been working
out in uh he does street photography as
well but he's been working in domba
since 2014.
um I met him on like my second or third
day working in Ukraine and to meet like
a seasoned photographer from this
country who
made some younger foreign guy who that
has never been in a war and like to be
very inviting and very helpful with like
sharing information
um every single time that we've spoken
he's like the sweetest best guy yevgeni
malaleca and uh Mr slav the AP guys who
stayed in marryable I had the chance to
meet them a little bit I think for like
two nights right before the war started
on like the 22nd and the 23rd and they
had said that they were planning on
heading to marry up
um Misty is from
Park of and then evgeny was from marry
up and like they had more connections
down there so they were planning on
doing that and them as well they were
like very open to helping to like give
information and like hey maybe you guys
should do this maybe you should do this
this is how you would do that um and
they sort of like helped us with the the
idea to head to Heart Kev if
um the war did break out oh yeah Maxim
johnjuk is one of my favorite we haven't
met in person but I think the the very
peaceful photos of chaos that he's able
to make are like Renaissance paintings
of what's been happening and like his
work from my Dawn is I think some of the
best that's out there
um hopefully one day I can meet him but
big fan I know the the guy that was the
photographer in azov Stall that made the
just like unbelievable photo of the
soldier standing in like the beam of
light in the destroyed building like
arms open and like this like light
pillar coming down and hitting him is
like one of the most remarkable things
um that's one of the most incredible
photos I've seen throughout all of this
um there was the the photo of like the
woman who had saved all of the dogs from
your pen again I'm not sure who who made
that photo but that is just like
unbelievable
um then yevgeny and Mr Slavs work for
Mary ubal from the Maternity Ward and
like their work in just like the
hospital and staying down there and then
also like getting the first photos of
like Russian tanks coming into that City
and like the the one tank that fired at
a residential building
those two guys I think have done like
some of the most like harrowing heroic
work
[Music]
this isn't like the whole War this is
just like the larger not just the larger
invasion of like the war that started in
2014. the way that I think I've come to
understand this or be taught about this
is that this is a little bit like in a
way like the Final Act of Ukraine's
Revolution and separation from
the USSR and Soviet Union and Russia as
a whole and kind of
forming or solidifying their sovereignty
so this kind of in a way it started a
thousand years ago in a way it started
in 91 with the breakup of the Soviet
Union in a way it started in 2014 and I
think these these are all just chapters
in the history of Ukraine but I think
that this may be the final part of
not the relationship with the Russia but
like the separation and breaking away
from the tie of Russia wanting to
control this land it's an interesting
thing to watch a nation make its own
history and like Forge its own path
um and finding their national identity
and like it's for a lot of Ukraine
that's still happening like there's a
huge part that is like they have their
idea of like what this country is and
like what it will be and like what it's
always been I think that there's a
everyone needs to get on the same page
and everyone needs to feel included at
some point in this
and Russia in the meantime is preying on
those divisions
[Music]
any journalists or younger folks that
are coming here like whether it's like
you've been here a lot or it's your
first time I think just like trying to
go to as many different areas and
speaking to as many different people
about the history of this or their
family's history of this
um because it can it can differ so much
here and opinions on things because it's
all it's politics and where you stand is
deeply affected by like where your
family was before this and like their
their experiences and stuff and try and
learn what's happening and why that is
from folks that are here and living it
um I think is the most important part